[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
now there are those lovely matches and
League of Legends where the Nexus means
nothing and kills mean everything
moments where two teams come together
and paint a picture so messy and so
disjointed that we have no choice but to
call it a clown Fiesta so buckle up
because you're in for one hell of a ride
we present to you the top 10 clown
fiestas in the league of legends history
enjoy kicking off our list are the
series of unfortunate events that took
place during a 2016 EU LCS match between
Rockets and unicorns of love after
seeing rocket rotate towards the bottom
of the map to secure a kill on their
split pusher the unicorns tried to
respond with a highly questionable Baron
attempt using their long ranged
abilities rocket were able to force UAL
off of Baron killing one member in the
process but with two of their enemies
down rocket decided to try and take
baron themselves yeah this is good
actually this is an ill-advised start on
the back of you goes however if they
stall for 15 seconds or longer visit
Joshi will join the back end of this
fight look at the damage from Baron the
men just going low mystic shot from
Veritas doesn't connect though it on the
side lanes move is still trying to put
some pressure down now to be fair this
fiestas impact on the game was minimal
that is until they did it again
expecting this - it looks like Halley's
gonna block big shots here is Eli gets
killed
both shots of critical this is becoming
risky now too
of battle because Forster run away to
finish this please somebody make up your
mind go for your body go for the bear
and make the smile but do something
after finally securing the Baron buff
uol were able to wash off their clown
makeup and bolster their advantage with
a split push strategy consistently
destroy 203 points
congratulations coming in at number 9 is
a 2016 na LCS match that sought both
dignitas and renegades feel the full
wrath of the rift in what was supposed
to be a run-of-the-mill match between
two teams from the premier for fun
region both renegades and Dignitas went
on to make a series of egregious
mistakes that took the game to
exponential levels of Fiesta this far
they can make those plays if it comes to
it exactly the double turret so you get
the gold back right did they shut down
the turrets for me that's right at four
minutes in summoners rift managed to
rack up four kills the rest of the game
was a back and forth affair with neither
team able to get a stranglehold on the
other and after 45 minutes the game
ended just how we thought it would with
a backdoor play by Sarah
Sara put the fire we called the top
laner would make plays in his
substitution and Sara comes forth to do
so Renegades
Kate's down team dignitas coming in at
number 8 we have rock at vs misfits in
the final week of the 2017 you LCS
summer split now both teams were already
locked in the standings ahead of this
match so neither team had anything to
gain and boy did they play like it
misfits brought out some off meta picks
and soloqueue strategies I mean while
rocket decided to throw out their
playbook entirely what deed has smite 2
so I think would deed is jungling up
against Mac slow his top lane
foxy might be mid with pride Sokka and
Betsy in the bottom Lane welcome to the
EU LCS the stage was perfectly set for a
Fiesta and right from the get-go it was
not short on clowny shenanigans first
blood on this
they're pulling him back but he's going
charging all the same cop to office Carl
maybe it's not even up yet
and it looks like you are almost in for
first club but ignore blue flash Musti
raise your doggers well they should be
able to do it in fact they want to go
for it when it's gonna be able to get
the finishing blow ride soccer he wants
to do the 1v1 but he cans in the 2v2
bets he getting pulled back in now and
it looks like misfits lose the tower but
get the kills some fiery died max Lou
died Betsy type rights and five people
those died ok on the back of Woody's
lease in mechanics of all things Brock
at was able to secure the victory in
this twenty nine minute barn burner
coming in at number seven is the longest
game in na LCS history in week 8 of the
2014 summer split this match between
complexity and curse was not considered
a must watch that is until it became a
[ __ ] show for the ages the first 50
minutes were a timid affair however
after a team fight by curse and
subsequent push down mid we thought the
end of his insight man were we wrong
this looks like they bought enough time
ten seconds left for Robert to come back
it's not beautiful lockdown bouncing
hurry about the retaliation
oh they're fighting
that's the shockwave it's all about pets
right now do they have enough focus to
continue negative after a lot of
posturing and stalling the crowd had had
enough nobody's gonna have to take a hit
sooner or later got to do it oh man and
so had the teams who's gonna do who's
gonna heal top it's going in looks like
Raleigh on the outside Robert actually
taking quite a bit of damage the
shockwave was used but did not do enough
for the team Curtis now on the back foot
nobody's gone down and the home guards
are definitely gonna help but with the
complexities moving it did they keep up
the inhibitor - whatever
should be good here you don't play with
fire what are you doing here now cops
play with fire
[Applause]
besides fight after fight after fight
wasn't enough for either team to end the
game
so Robert Exley took matters into his
own hands taking advantage of a
preoccupied curse he went through the
front door closing out the 80 minute
game in true clown fiesta style
[Applause]
simply with a game
at number six is a match between kt
rolster and kong do monster that shook
korean macro to its core with only one
series win in the entire spring split
Kong do played what could have been
their final match with a focus on
stopping KT at all costs they're still
going they are diving under turret now
there is crush heal - yeah - try a baby
didn't work out that was really well
played by Kate's low score what are you
doing okay some day why this what
happened bandage on its rocket time
goodbye some day oh wall ready let's do
that okay well that was really silly
[Laughter]
after 40 minutes it took one final
poorly executed fiesta that saw Kong do
wipeout Katie to tie the bow on this
horrendous ly enjoyable match collusion
and clowns this 2012 MLG rally final
match between Dignitas and curse comes
in at number five on our list going into
the match Dignitas and curse had plans
to kick off their MLG rally finals match
with an a ram and the rest of the story
would live in infamy if that's real I'll
eat my hat because that is bonkers
that's real I it's gonna be a good game
but it could be a bit weird they're
gonna get a gallant poke on sauce the
tower my dad against to get the slow and
Westeros imma cutie pies go very deep he
was tired eyes rest eyes he XE just
wants to go far that's all a theory that
just want to simply go back and buy Sri
she runs make abuse of the rules at
night Jackie should get taking out drugs
bunches to get the kill there the poison
elements go steep
he gets one can he get battered down no
he's surely
stop down I'll fix it down there West
right now is also getting a taking out
Skaro with Teemo this is the weirdest
League of Legends final I've ever
compensated in my life after holding the
lead throughout the entire game Dignitas
would close out the 150 kill bloodbath
at 30 minutes it was indeed 85 66 31
minutes god thanks for making me casted
out on guys after the match MLG
officials accused the teams of
conspiring to split the prize money and
both teams were disqualified forfeiting
their winnings team curse released an
apology for clouding the fans and
themselves and choosing to a ram in the
first game however neither team admitted
to splitting the pot number 4 on our
list is a true champions deep cut CJ
frost vs kt rolster be the 2013
champions spring series between the top
two teams in their division CJ frost and
kt rolster b was supposed to be a
heavyweight bout instead it turned into
a circus due to both teams desire to
lose
[Music]
I mean if we saw shy play a champion
like what does grabs are even doing he
wants all the waiver you wanted to kill
now the winner of this series would be
placed on the undesirable side of the
playoff bracket they'd have to go
through two powerhouse teams
CJ Blais and najin sword in order to get
to the finals and in the hopes of
dodging them both teams committed to the
Fiesta are you ready for the club what
I'm not trying to throw what was even
doing
kill him unfortunately for CJ frost they
soon realized that despite their efforts
to throw they had built a solid lead in
the game with Katy caught in a fight at
barren minions would flood their base
and CJ was forced to take the series win
coming in at number three is the match
between Brazilian red canids and Turkish
supermassive at MSI 27 teams play in
stage with the standings locked and
super massive set to move on to the
group stage there was only one thing
left to fight for in this match the
revered title of king of clowns
there should be a game filled with
smiles filled with aggressive League of
Legends it's not going to be quite so
lucky that you used to sing but a much
more organized scrimmage version of solo
queue everyone wants to kill everybody
both of these teams were dedicated to
the Fiesta giving the fans a true show
with wall-to-wall action another two on
two that family has been jumped off by
Beaufort there but the snare connects a
rowboat he comes back down for playful
tracer he goes you're a don't try to the
mists they've only closed them down that
fabulous is trying to run away there's
nowhere to go there is no Edgar but he's
gonna fight him actually you're into
trouble mister shoot fire but he's gonna
fall boyfriend of die again and that boy
just watches as once again it's just a
graveyard of the top side of the map
it's try to leader first and
this up here Lance the Q join it for the
five fabulous turns around touching the
damage with the playful trickster ain't
gotta stick is not a dead check or a
good shield coming up with stomata and
Pamela it's gonna fall as roy burgers on
the killing spree as the red Bubba's
bully Oh finally bullies mighty fiancée
T gets a buzz kill heels up trying to
run away but look at the cuff oh good
shield coming up dude while they were
neck and neck throughout most of the
game red cannon started winning fights
to amass a large gold lead down to the
March next Lance the carrots I'll kick
back into the team Roy Baker seed gives
Yoda a double kill stoppage is the next
target brother picks up that one
supermassive would not back down however
putting up a great 20-minute base
defense in the end it took brtt's twitch
aggressively face tanking the enemy team
to close out this 40 minute fiesta
coming in at number 2 on our list is the
match between Brazilian kaboom and
Turkish super massive at MSI 28 teams
playing stage with standings locked
there was only one thing left to fight
for in this match the revered title of
wait haven't we done this one already
ah [ __ ] here we go again while the
feeling of deja vu gave us an idea of
what was to come
this regional rematch for king of clowns
did not disappoint
I'm going with Lee sin top lane got it
Ramis for all these Auto attackers
this man is is the cheese pick master
and it looked like again Brazil had a
coronation in their future we see a
little bit here on James CC we should
now in trouble ranger site not there as
well Rio fest on a block anything there
but that fabulous is getting it sold out
stop attacking the rabbit
[Applause]
after winning a fight in the jungle
kaboom had the opportunity to end the
game but they decided to stall it out
for one last dance with a decisive
teamfight in their own base
super-massive went out on their own
terms and surrendered the game topping
our list at number one is the LPL s
biggest
inside-joke Oscar night going into the
final series in the 2015 spring split
neither LGD nor IG wanted to win winning
meant a higher seed in the standings and
being placed on the same side of the
bracket as the region's definitive best
team EDG however throwing games is
against the rules
so LGD and IG needed to look like they
were playing to win a TCS 269 they're in
the mid lane though is oh my goodness
kid's gonna get grabbed on his way back
in here if with a massive flip into the
bottom line that's the tempered fate kid
still going to die almost donates that
kill over to God be there in the mid
lane which probably would have been
worse while we've seen this premise
before it was the artful performance of
the teams that turned this game into a
masterpiece Nicolas and he's taking no
damage as the ball there is over a bit
of a shield got me looking to come
through this I swap actually and he just
gets eliminated probably wishes that he
had as Anya's algaas available there
trying to be inconspicuous these clowns
were hiding in plain sight this is it
just a brilliant strategy Atlas we've
seen we've seen yeah telephones fight
off ladders now we're seeing in ignites
wide top laner and a teleport flash
jungler yeah Kakao gets the permafrost
here as well TB q what he has is
mobility as CB q just gonna try and
clear out this creep wave
cuz this Szechuan e is impossible to
remove does get the dragon rage back up
again but in the meantime the inhibitor
turret is falling down hahaha some
cheeky behavior here from tbq and they
just proxy farming against each other
then yeah once again circumventing the
week early jungling kbq can dive yeah
he's going for some sort of dug these
lightweights coming through the time
looking for it
The Lost Auto attack does have the
shield is he gonna be out of land at
there it is following a completely
disjointed engage by LG d IG could stall
no longer ending the game and
effectively ending their chance at
winning the split well guys that's our
list you made it this far it probably
means you're not afraid of clowns be
sure to LIKE the video subscribe to our
Channel and let us know in the comments
what other League toptenz you'd like to
see see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]